okay great yeah thanks so much for
coming to my talk today yeah this is
based on a series of joint works with uh
John Jerry Allan and Aon um yeah let's
get started
so okay so this uh series of Works was
motivated by like um a couple of
theoretical Oddities um and perhaps like
uh places where the analysis of existing
theoretical algorithms for solving
linear inverse problems had some
shortcomings um so I'll use the first
third of the talk to maybe uh give some
brief overview of the state-of-the-art
like what is known for sparse recovery
and Matrix completion and also what new
things are algorithms bring to the table
and then I'll use the second third of
the talk to sort of like highlight a
particular uh you know structural aspect
of our proofs that I think uh I'm I'm
curious to see if it will have
implications in other settings and I
think it's particularly self-contained
so hopefully uh that part will will be
the only part with a proof and then I'll
use like the last third to like very
briefly sneak in uh our generalization
to The Matrix comption set okay so uh
let's talk about spress recovery so in
spress recovery we want to solve an
under constrained linear system so uh in
particular I imagine you have n
observations of a hidden variable um n
linear observations and N is much less
than D so this is clearly impossible in
the worst case and you need to assume
something more about your problem and
the typical structural assumption people
make um in The Spar cury literature is
that the planted solution xstar is
sparse um here you should think of s a
parameter that's much less than D okay
um so what about algorithms for solving
this problem well a sort of a minimal
assumption you need about uh the problem
formulation is that a doesn't contain
any sparse is vectors in its kernel so
in particular if it has um a 2s sparse
Vector in its kernel I can move with in
that direction and create another sparse
solution so this is called the
restricted npace property and uh it's
sort of uh been known for like decades
at this point that uh under this
assumption uh with particular par like
some parameterization of r&p um the
convex programming relaxation of
minimizing the L1 Norm subject to uh
matching all the constraints uh it Sol
solves the problem in polinomial
time okay and uh this is a very like
desirable algorithm in many ways so it's
very flexible it generalizes uh to noisy
settings just fine um and it uses
essentially minimal assumptions about
the problem all you need is that a
satisfies
r&p uh but the only downside although I
know like many in this room are like
working hard to uh you know alleviate
even this downside is that it's
potentially expensive in high Dimensions
to run a generic convex programming
solver okay um on the other hand uh if
you assume something stronger about a
that it satisfies this thing called
known as the restricted isometry
property or rip which basically means
that not only does it not contain sparse
vectors in its kernel it like really
preserves the uh it's like a near
isometry on all the sparse vectors so
for any V with ovs non-zero entries it
roughly preserves the the L2 Norm of V
uh you can actually design near linear
time algorithms um and basically in this
setting uh there are many different
approaches to make it work you could do
greedy algorithms you can do non-convex
algorithms you can do like projected
gradient descent type algorithms and
these all run in near linear time under
this rip assumption okay so um in theory
you know under standard generative
models like for example uh if you assume
a has IID rows drawn from some
reasonable ens
uh both work just fine and uh in in
general like these Attain faster run
times but in practice it seems that uh
you know based on like real data sets
people care about a variety of Works
have reported that these fast methods
seem to be much more brittle um in terms
of like is the Assumption actually
satisfied um so what's going on here and
uh our investigation of this problem
sort of started by uh noticing that uh
these uh convex programming based
polinomial time algorithms are very
robust under a natural semi- random
adversary we introduce in particular uh
even if you perturb the instance by the
semi- random adversary which I'll Define
uh momentarily uh the algorithms
continue to work just fine however in
the near linear time setting um this RP
assumption and a variety of structural
assumptions used by these uh these fast
algorithms are immediately broken by the
adversary we introduce
okay so um I want to take a quick aside
here to like pitch this notion of a
semi- random model it's not a general
like uh one siiz fits-all definition but
in general here's the philosophy behind
semi- random models so it's sort of a
way of interpolating between the worst
case and the fully random best case
scenario in statistical algorithms so in
a lot of these statistical settings if
you make no assumptions structural
assumptions on your problem whatsoever
uh it's usually like very hard or maybe
even information theoretically
impossible to solve the problem but if
you assume certain like nice properties
about your problem in like maybe it's
IID or fully random in some setting then
all of a sudden you have these like very
fast polinomial time algorithms and um
semi- random models are sort of a way of
testing an algorithm's overfitting to
its problem assumptions so it's asking
what happens in this intermediate regime
where uh you don't have like the fully
best case assumption but maybe you still
have enough information in your instance
to solve the problem information
theoretically uh can we design
algorithms which compete with the ones
that work in the fully random setting so
sort of the motto is if everything works
when life is easy but we want to solve
problems maybe where life isn't so easy
we want to design an algorithm that is
the most robust to um the structural
assumptions we're actually using in the
problem
okay so uh yeah now I'll introduce our
like instantiation of this philosophy in
the setting of Spar recovery so recall
that here is the setting you have n
linear measurements of a sar Spector and
in the in the nearly linear time
algorithms they typically assume that a
has this nice property that it preserves
uh sparse vectors
approximately okay so the basic semi-
random adversary we introduce is the
following so you imagine your Matrix is
not fully rip it contains like a planted
rip Matrix so some subset of of the rows
are nice and then an adversary comes and
gives you like additional consistent
information so they're not lying to you
what AI times XR is they are really
telling you the truth but they're just
making this assumption that your Matrix
is fully rip uh violated
okay so here's the full definition you
take an RP Matrix you add some
additional consistent measurements and
then I just Shuffle it so that I you
don't know which ones are are the real
are the random ones and which ones are
the semi- random ones what fraction of
rows can you yeah so I'll get to that uh
shortly uh I mean our algorithms will
work for any uh fraction of rows but
they actually get better uh the more uh
the more rows you assume are like random
versus
semi okay so I just want to uh remind
the audience that like we haven't really
changed the information theoretic or
even like the polinomial time um
solvability of this problem because you
can still solve uh the comx Rel
relaxation like in particular note that
by giving additional rows I can't like
decrease the size of the kernel right um
so it still satisfies
r&p but you know you can probably guess
the next thing I'm about to say um it
this sort of semi randum adversary can
arbitrarily hinder uh the ripness of a m
so in particular um you can construct
explicit counter examples where like
many greedier non-convex iterative
methods like immediately fail um and
furthermore uh these convex iterative
methods seem to like projected gradient
set seem to rely on some sort of like
restricted problem conditioning which is
also very easy to break using the semi-
random Addis
here okay so what's our first results is
um you can you can solve these planted
rip matrices uh sparse recovery problems
in them in near linear time so I'm
hiding one detail which is that you do
have to assume that sort of uh the The
Matrix doesn't have any too large
entries but in typical models you can uh
this this is just true in basically any
standard RP construction I know and you
can just sort of drop any row that is
obviously semi-
random okay so uh you might not be
satisfied with this results like for
example like okay I'm assuming axr is
exactly equal to B what happens if I add
some noise um as Santos asks uh what
happens if I like actually give you like
a larger fraction of RP rows like uh can
I kind of recover the rate uh given by
like the information theoretically
minimum number of rows and then also
like this notion of pip seems like quite
like structured it's like where in real
life are you going to encounter someone
who just hands you some real random rows
and someone who hands you some
non-random row right and fortunately we
have another theorem that uh sort of
addresses all of these simultaneously
I'm going to like maybe not uh Focus too
much on it but just note that we uh we
give a recovery rate that depends on uh
the noise in some instance optimal way
and then our algorithm also has a
runtime that interpolates between the
fully random case and the semi- random
case so if uh you know I give you n rows
and N is much larger than the
information theoretically minimum like s
then I still run an SD time um also yeah
we generalize the notion of an adversary
to handle weights so I'm not going to
spend too much time on this particular
slide but I just want to give you a
sense of the flavor of results we were
able to
attain okay so that's spish recover
and then uh you know like any uh good
TCS researchers we solve the vector
problem we ask all right what about the
Matrix problem so uh here's a natural
generalization of this problem to The
Matrix setting you could just Define
your a hidden Vector to be a matrix and
then you define like linear measurements
through matrices right so this this is a
problem studied in uh like phase
retrieval among other things and uh the
natural generalization of sparseness is
just a a yes question sorry uh maybe you
can repeat the question I don't have mic
oh yeah sure sure um so I think in this
before we move on yes there I think
there is some kind of like when you have
ill conditioned matrices there is still
like a computational statistical Gap
like polinomial time versus exponential
time
algorithms um if the Matrix was Ill
condition so I mean you can always solve
this guy polinomial time uh but oh sorry
when you have noise when you have noise
when you have noise you can kind of like
relax this constraint to have some L2
error and this will also just work fine
ah but I thought in the noisy case the
recovery that you get from the convex
program doesn't match the best
exponential time algorithm yeah so okay
yeah so I'm I'm hiding some slight like
uh yeah so you depend on like sort of
like the worst coordinates of the noise
so like among the worst uh rows in your
Matrix so yeah there's there's some sort
of like even tighter in optimality that
you can go for which I'm not going to
talk about so is this like matching the
conx program or the expon this is
matching the comics program
yeah cool okay um yeah so Matrix price
recovery so the natural I'm just GNA
like quickly skip over this because I'm
not going to talk about it too much but
basically the natural way of formulating
this is instead of assuming that your
planted solution is sparse you assume
it's low rank which is like spectral
sparsity and then you also require sort
of like at least Dr observations just by
a dimension counting argument to give
you a rank R Matrix and D Dimensions I
need Dr parameters okay so uh you know
we actually did not work on this problem
but uh at nearest 2023 you can ask Singa
and Yu Chung who recently posted a paper
called robust Matrix sensing in the
semi- random model which generalizes our
algorithm to this setting okay so what
what what was what was our team working
on um our team was working on a specific
case of this which is has arguably
incomparable assumptions to Matrix
sensing Matrix completion so this is
famously uh piloted by like I think it's
made famous like in the TCS community at
least by the Netflix Challenge and sort
of understanding uh algorithms for
solving it but the setting here is that
the observation matrices are like very
interpretable they're just they just
correspond to like a particular entry of
your hidden Matrix right so given
roughly Dr random observations of the
Matrix can I recover The Matrix right
okay so the thing to not note about uh
The Matrix completion setting is that
some sort of rip type assumption
is sort of impossible so what do I mean
by rip type assumption recall that an RP
assumption is like a for all type
statement it's saying for all sparse
vectors um these observations sort of
preserve the the vector right but here
if you try to make this sort of
statement for all rank R matrices um the
observations sort of preserve the Matrix
like this is clearly false because if
you show me some observations I'm just
going to like hide a spike where you
missed it and you can't tell me anything
about that observation right um so what
sort of things can people do in this
setting
um so you have to kind of make an
additional structural assumption which
is that you dodge this kind of worst
case behavior and typically uh the way
this is phrased is uh uh the row and
column uh spans of xstar are spread in
some way they don't place too much mass
on any particular coordinate so this is
known as incoherence um yeah the
technical definition doesn't matter too
much but basically it means that it
doesn't favor any coordinate too much
okay so under these assumptions what do
people know how to do so in polinomial
time um you know the natural thing one
would try is uh to solve the Min nuclear
Norm solution instead of like the Min L1
solution um and after a long series of
Works uh uh re in 2011 shows that
roughly Dr samples are uh able to um
make sure that this convex program
actually does recover The Matrix under
this incoherence
assumption okay uh what about in near
linear time so uh the stateoftheart that
doesn't have uh dependencies on other
like more than logarithmic dependencies
on other problem parameters like
conditioning um is due to Jan and nrop
in 2015 and they showed that by using
some kind of like clipped projected
gradient descent you're able to uh get
an algorithm that it takes uh more
samples than the polytime algorithms but
it runs uh you know much faster uh well
in in in some parameter regimes uh Dr to
the seven time
okay okay so uh you you might look at
these and this is also under incoherence
and you might look at these results and
immediately two things might pop out so
uh these rates while while good are
still not uh not quite as good as we can
do in poly time and also um yeah so this
this Assumption of incoherence like why
is this the right assumption uh can we
say anything when it doesn't satisfy
incoherence and interestingly a third uh
axis of uh the state-of-the-art in
Matrix completion is the noise
robustness of these algorithms so
suppose instead I give you observations
from um mstar a rank R Matrix plus some
fenus Norm bounded noise well actually
uh even the polinomial time algorithms
we don't know how to Output a rank R
solution that is more than root D time
Delta um away from the truth so this uh
I'm not personally aware of any uh
barriers to removing this rot D Factor
so this is like a a question interesting
question even polinomial time okay so
our results uh is best phrased in two
stages so the first stage of our results
is um given a rank R Matrix mstar note
that I make no assumptions about
incoherence or anything like this um
plus some fbus Norm bounded noise uh I
can give you a matrix M that recovers
mstar to error o of Delta not quite it
recovers it to error o of Delta on a 99%
by 99% of all rows and columns so um
yeah this is actually the first sort of
results of this uh nature uh we were
aware of in the literature and it's
saying like uh the price of dropping
this spread assumption is that well some
of the coordinates aren't going to be
good but if you just remove a few very
bad coordinates you can still get
roughly optimal guarantees okay and we
do this using um Dr samples hiding a sub
polinomial factor and Dr squar time okay
so that's part one and then in part two
um we show how to boost this partial
completion result to full results
assuming some sort of like spread
assumptions on the Subspace so we
introduce this new notion called a
regular Subspace uh this is Satisfied by
random subspaces with high probability
uh we're able to take roughly the same
sample complexity in time and lose a
little bit in the accuracy but it's
still like poly R rather than root D and
then finally under the standard
assumption our samples and time go up by
like roughly a r
factor Matrix is not actually low rank
uh the The Matrix we output is also low
rank uh you can kind of just project to
the rank R Subspace and lose only a
constant factor in the
distance still going to be r or you BL
up no like like give given a rank larger
than R Matrix if I just truncate it to
rank R this doubles the distance to
off okay
cool okay so uh yeah uh wow that took
longer than I was expecting okay so uh
I'll try to show you one proof I think
this is like a a cool takeaway from our
work and sort of inspired the entire
line of work so um yeah so in uh when
you first like this is optimization
minded audience when you first saw the
RP definition you might be like oh this
sounds kind kind of like well
conditioning right um in fact it's like
some sort of restricted well
conditioning so for example if I told
you the support of xstar it really is a
well condition problem right I just need
to like restrict to that set okay so I
can actually do you one better um if you
assume your Matrix is Rip it's actually
uh well conditioned on a larger set of
vectors called numerically sparse so
roughly speaking these are things that
have a bounded L1 to L2 ratio um the
proof is via some simple like shelling
argument I won't go into it now okay so
uh you know you might see this and then
a plan starts forming in your head and
maybe the plan looks something like this
so uh it sounds like if we just make
sure that our iterates lie in the set
and then we do something else then we
win okay well uh yeah how do you do that
well I can't tell you how to do the
second line but I can tell you how to do
the first line which is um maybe you
want to maintain some L1 projection
right this at least make sure that the
the top is bounded right and the
question is sort of in this framework um
how do you reason about the effect of
this L1 projection okay so this is where
our key geometric Insight comes into
play so the the punch line is sort of if
you hit a random a unit vector v with a
random gausian Matrix uh all directions
other than b are flat okay so what what
does that mean so um suppose you have a
so I'm gonna abuse notation and let the
rows of a be like one over root n AI um
if you hit V with a random gausian
Matrix so all the AIS are IID
gausian okay so I'm going to write each
AI um in the following way I'm going to
decompose it into the V Direction and
then into the all the orthogonal
directions and uh the thing to note is
that ai ai transpose V like it really
accumulates in the v Direction because
you get this SI squared term but
everything else is basically random
right and if I average a bunch of these
well it won't it'll definitely pick up
the V Direction but it'll certain of not
favor any particular other direction and
in particular um this other Vector is
essentially random so it's l Infinity
bounded and uh it's not hard to convince
yourself that the trade-off is roughly 1
over root n times maybe root
log okay so uh a little more formally
here's the statement if you have an RP
Matrix a with parameter s and you hit V
with a transpose a there exists a short
flat decomposition of the results so
there exists a decomposition to PV and
EV p is like the progress Direction it's
um L2 Norm bounded by roughly what V was
and E is the error Direction um but it's
l Infinity bounded and this will let us
quantify the effect of L1
projection okay so a quick overview of
why projected gradient Ascent Works
armed with this new insight so um
suppose for Simplicity we're in this
regime where x minus xar so xar is our
Target Vector is L2 Norm bounded by one
and L1 Norm bounded by root
S uh so okay case one is that actually
its L2 Norm is so our goal here is just
going to be like to have the L2 Norm so
case one is actually like it was better
than I thought and then we're just done
right but in the second case if the lorm
is large then we're just going to use a
transpose AV as a descent Direction and
okay and the point is that this is a
good idea by the Lemma so informally
it's because you can write it into the
progress Direction which is where you
actually want to go and then you have
this error term uh which is filtered out
by the L1 projection and this is by
holders
inequality okay so gonna maybe like skip
over this a little bit but the idea is
um you start by drawing an L1 ball
around your current Point uh if if
you're numerically sparse uh if you're
not numerically sparse the only reason
you could have been not numerically
sparse is because the denominator got uh
got smaller than you think it is and
that means you've have the LT radius and
you can move on otherwise we can run
some pgd and okay so uh yeah just
projected gradient
descent
and the thing I want to alert your
attention to is that the one step we
check which is that the progress
Direction was really good and The
Descent Direction has a short flat
decomposition this is like full this
this fully makes sense in the semi-
random setting as well and this is sort
of like the only thing we need for our
algorithm to make progress so in the
semi- random setting the idea is we're
just going to maintain some weights on
the rows note that by choosing the
weights to be the uh the random rows I
can recover like the thing I was
supposed to do but then you can just
solve some convex optimization problem
to make sure that this line passes and
uh we show how to do that in your linear
time using some
SGD okay
um okay so this is like for the
optimization experts in the room which
is like many of you like this is
probably the only talk I can get away
with a slide like this so I'm just going
to go ahead and do it uh ignore my
shamelessness okay so if you've seen any
like pgd proof at all it probably goes
something along the lines of this um you
have the progress term which is how much
closer you're getting to the Target and
then you have these two terms so this is
like the Descent Direction and then this
is some like proximity term okay and the
idea is we're going to break this uh
this descent Direction down into XT
minus xar and xt- XT +1 and we're
further going to Define uh we're going
to break down the gradient term into the
short part and the flat part so this is
the flat part and this is the short
part and the point is by restricted well
conditioning this term is Big right it's
saying that um because XT minus xar is a
numerically sparse Direction I will make
progress okay what about everything else
uh this is flat and this is L1 bounded
boom holder uh this is L2 bounded and
then this is uh Koshi Schwarz yabble
boom bounded all right that's the whole
proof okay so yeah with the last five
minutes I will talk a little bit about
Matrix
completion yeah so in Matrix completion
land uh what would be the right way of
defining a short flat decomposition so a
natural thing to try is first write down
the gradient right the gradient is sort
of like um the residuals of the current
Matrix along the observations so
basically you want to take your current
Matrix subtract off the truth which you
can see on some observations I'm
denoting the observations by Omega and
then you like rescale it by one over p p
is the observation probability to sort
of like make sure it's unbiased so this
is like the natural descent Direction
one might
try so the natural thing one might try
to do following the outline in the SP
recovery case is to write this as the
sum of a short term and a flat term so
formally uh consider decomposing this
into the progress Direction so if we
just took the progress Direction M minus
M Star we would immediately land where
we wanted to and then the goal is to
show that the residual Matrix the error
term is flat so flat here means like
spectrally flat L Infinity bounded in
other words op Norm
bounded so I show you a matrix like this
and I ask you to control the operator
Norm you might think all right that
sounds like uh Matrix Bernstein is the
is is the one for the job and Matrix
buring controls so you can write this as
sort of like a sum of uh dqu random
matrices each one corresponds to a
single entry okay and um Matrix brinin
requires two parameters it requires a
entry-wise bound so like sort of a
probability one bound on your random
matrices um that in this case it
corresponds to every entry being small
and then it also requires a variance
bound so you can you can work out the
calculation roughly speaking the
variance bounding Matrix brinin
corresponds to every row and column of M
minus M Star being small okay uh okay so
of course this is not true in general
because again like single spikes totally
ruin this but it's actually totally okay
if you drop like 1% of rows and columns
so the point is um how many rows can be
larger than like 100 times the average
you know L2 squared Norm U maybe like
one one% just Markov right okay the one
that's like a little bit harder to see
is the entry-wise bound but you can show
that for any rankar Matrix it can't have
too many disjoint um large entries or
else this would violate the nuclear Norm
so you can also get away with dropping
like 1% of Ros for that okay so then
like why is the paper like 50 pages long
it's because you know then you have to
like go back and recover these drops
rows and columns and also like in Matrix
land uh you can't like in in Vector land
uh if you have a sar Spector or a dpar
Spector you can still do things in O ofd
time but if you don't maintain that your
iterates are low rank in The Matrix case
you can't even like do efficient
computation so you have to kind of like
make sure that your matrices ranks don't
blow up even um so that's that's for a
later
talk okay and then um yeah so more
generally I'm curious about like uh um
how much this like structural setting
where you like you really charact use
the structural characteristic
characteristics of your problem to um
analyze the effect of the noise and then
use some sort of geometry to filter that
out um I think it's an interesting
General framework for semi- random
inverse problems um and inverse problems
in general um I'm also curious like sort
of what types of harder adversaries we
can push our algorithm to tolerate so
Matrix completion gives like a slight
augmentation of this like for all type
statement where it's like it's more like
per Matrix um you give some guarantee
but uh I'd be curious how far we can
push the envelope in terms of the
adversary okay thank
you thanks Kevin we have time for a
question well I have a question
um do you note empirically that these
algorithms are robust to these real data
situations that you started the talk
with then cosamp or yeah yeah right
right you might you might notice that
like this is written by like five
theorist like uh it's um yeah that's
that's the next step and we're yeah no
no we're we're in the we're in we're in
talks to try to make this make this
happen but the answer is no at the
moment but i' be really excited if I
have some experts in the audience who
would be interested in exploring this
framework for you know real data which
was the motivation for the
problem
yes yeah so just repeat the
question so importantly the the set of
rows we think is bad in each iteration
is changing iteration by iteration
because uh verifying RP is NP hard and
find no so it's like in each iteration
we're going to find some subset of rows
that currently works and like it's this
might change iteration by iteration but
the point is in each step here so
replace one over n with some sort of
like reweighting of the rows any weight
that works we're just going to take the
step you know a transpose uh a a trans a
reweighted by these W's and if you take
that step um the fact that you pass
these shows that you make progress um so
the entire computational game boils down
to uh finding these weights and we get
an algorithm as a near linear time but
there's certainly room for practice so
if I pass you a
stra probably
EXA yeah yeah so like if if it was truly
random like my intuition from the proofs
is just that like the W output is
uniform and then you just keep taking
that
stuff let's thank Kevin again and all
the speakers this
afternoon